MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we continue our discussion
now of electron and proton
scattering.
And we dive deep into
the structure using
deep inelastic scattering.
Inelastic here means
that we are destroying
the structure of the proton
in the scattering process.
But we have a way to look
at the remnant of the proton
and also of the
scattered electron,
and then compare our
theoretic expectation
for the cross-sections with
the finding in experiments.
Let me just talk about
this in more general terms.
The energy of the probing
electron or the photon
in the scattering
process allows us
to look at the proton
with varying resolution.
So at very low
energies, we basically
see a point-like particle.
And then the scattering
process looks
very much like the scattering
of an electron with a muon.
If we increase the
energy of the electron,
we can see that there's
an extended charge
distribution in the proton.
Further increase allows
us to resolve the fact
that the proton is made
out of three quarks.
And if you increase
the energy further,
we see a lot of new
particles appearing, quarks
and antiquarks and
gluons, which make up
the structure of the proton.
The picture here is--
I like this very much, I drew
this myself some years ago--
is what I would like
to have you remember.
So in deep inelastic
scattering experiments,
we basically use the
photon scattered--
radiated off the
electron as a magnifying
glass for the proton.
So we can look into the
structure of the proton here,
and we see the distribution
of the charged particles
in the proton--
only the electrically-charged
particles.
We don't have
scattering between--
direct scattering between
photons and gluons.
So in measurements,
what we can do
is we can test
scattered electron,
and we can look for the
remnant of the proton
in our measurement, and then we
do differential cross-section
measurements, compare
with our theory,
and can infer information about
the structure of the proton.
To do this, we have special
kinematic variables which
turn out to be very useful.
The most important
one is probably
this x year, which is called
the Bjorken scaling x or Bjorken
x, which you can think about--
so this is q squared,
the momentum transfer
of the photon, p is the
momentum of the proton,
q is the momentum transfer,
this q here, factor of 2.
And what this is basically
the fraction of the momentum
carried by the parton here
in the scattering process.
There's a few other
useful variables,
but I don't want to go into
any of the details yet.
So there's a number of
very important scattering
experiments.
The first one I mentioned
before is SLAC-MIT experiment,
which led to the discovery
that the proton is made out
of quarks, and the Nobel
Prize in Physics 1990
to Jerry Friedman, Henry
Kendall, and Taylor.
And what they did
is they basically
had a beam at SLAC of
electrons of 5 to 20 GeV.
And they scattered this beam
off of hydrogen target protons.
And they used this
spectrometer here
in order to then make a
differential measurement
of the scattered electrons.
So that's very cool.
Even higher energies
were available
at HERA, the
electron-positron collider,
where the energies
of the electrons
were in the order of 30 GeV
of the protons up to 830 GeV.
And so what we find then
in those collisions,
the differential cross-section
measurements, is shown here.
And it's very-- not
an easy plot to read.
So you see our
structure functions
here in the logarithmic plot.
Remember, this is the
a log 10 plot here.
And you see here q squared,
the momentum transfer
of the photon, so the energy
used in the scattering process.
When we try to
read this here, we
can look at a fixed q
squared, for example.
And at a fixed q squared,
you see that if you probe--
if you are testing for a
fixed fraction of the partons
taking away partons, a
fraction of the parton's
momentum of the proton, you see
that the lower the fractions,
the more particles you see.
So at a fixed energy, you
see many, many more particles
the lower you go
in the fraction.
So there seem to be like
an increase of particles
the lower the fraction is.
If you then check for a fixed
fraction, let's say 0.4--
it means that the parton carries
40% of the proton's energy--
you see that it's almost flat
as a function of q squared.
So it seems like there's 40%--
the number of particles you
see at 40% of momentum fraction
is constant, this q squared.
However, if you look at smaller
energies-- sorry, smaller
momentum fractions, you
see that higher energies
seem to show even more particles
at this momentum fraction.
And the ways to understand
this is two diagrams.
So the first one
is this one here,
where you see a quark
radiating a gluon.
And so what you see is
that the deeper you look,
you are able to then
resolve this part here.
And so you see more
quarks and gluons
which carry even smaller
momentum fractions
than the initial quark here.
You also see diagrams
like this, which
is called gluon splitting,
as a gluon splits
into a quark/antiquark here.
And you start resolving those.
And those also carry
lower momentum.
The evolution of our--
of this parton distribution
function, or the structure
functions, can be
calculated and described
in the so-called
DGLAP equations.
And all you do here is
calculate the contributions
from the so-called quark
and gluon splitting.
So you calculate the
splitting functions,
these higher-order corrections
to a very simple quark model.
And you find that you can
actually very nicely describe
those curves here.
So you see this yellowing--
yellow here is
the QCD fit, which
basically uses those
splitting functions as input.
All right.
So we learned quite a bit
about this proton already.
If we want to now
calculate a cross-section
of a proton scattering
with a proton,
we are actually interested
in the energy distributions
or the momentum distributions
of the partons in the protons.
And so we'll come back
to how we use this later.
But I want to introduce parton
distribution functions which
do exactly that.
They're defined
as the probability
to find a parton in
the proton that carries
energy between x and x plus dx.
You can write them using the
structure functions before.
But they literally
describe this probability.
And so what you find
inside the protons are now
the valence quark, the down
quark and the up quarks,
c quarks and
antiquarks, and gluons.
So you want to describe
those momentum distributions
or energy distributions
of those particles.
There's a number of sum rules.
If you integrate momentum
fractions from 0 to 1,
1 being the momentum of the
proton, if you integrate them
all together, you
have to find 1,
because that is the momentum
of the proton you start with.
If you integrate the down
quarks and the up quarks,
you find 1 or 2,
meaning that those
are the number of valence
quarks we have available.
If you integrate
the distributions
of strange and antistrange
and charm and anticharm,
you get 0, because
there needs to be
the same number of
strange and antistrange
and charm and antistrange.
And because of
energy conservation,
the sum needs to-- this sum,
those sums need to be 0.
And then we can look at those.
So what's shown here is x
times the Parton Distribution
Functions, the PDFs,
as a function of f.
And what you see here
for our valence quarks,
you see a distribution which
is kind of what you expect--
it almost peaks at 0.3, a
surge, and has the distributions
because there's
kinematics involved,
and also interactions--
because of the interactions
with the gluons.
And then you see the c
quarks and antiquarks.
And you see them increasing
in numbers quite significantly
here as you go to small fraction
of the momentum carried.
It's exactly what we just
discussed in the previous plot
already.
An interesting way to look at
this very same distribution
function is if you plot them
proportional to the momentum
fractions, or the area
fractions.
And what you see there is
that a very significant part
of the momentum of the proton
is carried by the gluon.
So you see here again, our
valence quarks, our c quarks,
and the gluons itself.
So that's all I wanted to say
on the structure of the proton.
We'll later in a lecture see
how we can use those PDFs,
those Parton Distribution
Functions, in order
to calculate a cross-section
in proton scattering.